>> Announcer: From the Library
of Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Karen Lloyd: Good afternoon.
I'm Karen Lloyd, a retired Army
Division Colonel and Director
of the Veteran's
History Project.
Thank you for choosing to come
to our panel discussion on PTSD
and Veterans Correctional
Housing Units.
It's the second in our
ongoing PTSD panel series
in collaboration with
the National Institute
of Corrections.
I'd especially like
to welcome the members
of the Justice Involved
Veterans Network in attendance
and those watching online, a
group of industry professionals
who research and produce
recommendations on how
to help veterans involved
in the justice system.
It is the work they do
that makes these types
of discussions possible
and so valuable.
As an Army veteran, I know how
untreated PTSD can affect a
veteran's life.
Our partners at the
National Institute
of Corrections know all too well
how PTSD can create problems
with reentry into [inaudible]
and how it can lead to run-ins
with the law and entry into
the justice and prison systems.
But as you'll learn today, it
doesn't have to be this way.
We've pulled together
several experts
who have seen firsthand
how treating PTSD
and adding structure to
veteran inmates' lives
in the Veterans Correctional
Housing Units can break the
cycle of crime and recidivism.
This panel represents
just another example
of how the Veterans
History Project is working
to illuminate the work done by
a wide variety of organizations
that focus on assisting our
veterans to move forward
with their lives and further
enrich their life stories,
which we certainly hope
they then choose to donate
to the library so others can
benefit from their experiences.
While we had hoped to
have Director Inch today,
he sent the next-best
thing, a marine.
Our next speaker is Frank Lara
of the U.S. Bureau of Prisons.
Mr. Lara is a veteran of the
United States Marine Corp
and is currently the Assistant
Director of Congressional --
Correctional Programs Division.
Frank Lara began his --
began his career as a
correctional officer
in Seagoville, Texas, where
he rose through the ranks,
eventually being named Warden
at the Federal Correctional
Complex, Beaumont,
where he received the New
Warden of the Year Award
from the Bureau of Prisons.
In 2017, he became
the Assistant Director
of the Correctional
Programs Division.
So please, let -- help me
welcome Assistant Director Lara.
[ Applause ]
>> Frank Lara: Good afternoon.
>> Audience: Good afternoon.
>> Frank Lara: Thank you,
Karen, for that introduction.
I'm honored to be here, and we
did have a little discussion
with the Director this morning.
So he couldn't make it.
He had some unplanned
activities that were not
on his calendar that showed up.
So he feels he -- he
regrets not being here,
but I did tell him this.
I said, "Well, you're
sending a corporal.
That's equivalent to
a general in the Army.
So -- "
[ Laughter ]
He took that pretty good.
But as Karen mentioned, I've
served in the Bureau of Prisons
for over 26 years in
various capacities.
I've moved a total of 12 times.
This is my second
time back in DC,
and actually I've worked
two times at Beaumont,
one as a lieutenant,
and then second time
as the complex warden.
So that's one of the best
assignments I've had.
Prior to joining the
Federal Bureau of Prisons,
I proudly served in the
United States Marine Corp
for four years and exited the
Marine Corp as a corporal.
I'm here on behalf of the --
Mark Inch, Director of
the Bureau of Prisons,
and the 37,000 staff who serve
this agency and our country
at our 122 bureau
facilities nationwide.
Prior to assuming the
directorship, Mr. Inch served
as the Provost Marshal
General/Commanding General,
Criminal Investigative Division
in Army Corrections Command,
where he maintained the
Executive Management Oversight
of the Army Corrections System.
Every veteran, regardless
of when or where they served
or for how long, gave
of themselves to ensure
that all Americans continue
to enjoy the freedoms
and opportunities that are the
foundation of this country.
I know firsthand some of
the challenges veterans face
as a result of spending
time in places
and circumstances many
cannot even imagine.
We are here today to
increase the awareness
about Post Traumatic
Stress Disorder.
Some of these men and women
who suffer from PTSD struggle
to adapt back into society after
having served their country.
PTSD can also contribute
to their involvement
in the justice system.
Approximately 7%, or 200,000,
of the 2.3 million
people incarcerated
in our nation's jails and
prisons are men and women
who have served in
the armed forces.
The majority of these
individuals completed service
with an honorable discharge.
A significant portion
of the combat troops are
returning home affected
by visible and invisible battle
scars, including high rates
of PTSD and traumatic
brain injury,
as well as serious physical
mental -- serious wounds.
Some veterans return
home and struggle
and find themselves using
substances, and others struggle
with various forms of
mental illness related
to their deployments.
All of these issues
may, in some cases,
lead to justice system
involvement and incarceration.
Veteran-specific housing units
in our correctional environments
promotes opportunities
to assist veterans in
preparation to return
to our communities with
the skills and confidence
to be productive and
contributing members of society.
The Bureau of Prisons houses
nearly 11,000 veterans
nationwide across
our 122 facilities.
The vast majority are male,
although we do have
a small number
of female veterans as well.
We have an office devoted to
meeting the needs of the groups
of special inmates
with specialized needs.
In December of 2017, we formally
recognized the inmate veterans
as a special population.
We have a wide variety of
services for veteran inmates,
but we are in the process
of standardizing
services nationwide.
We have developed a three-tiered
services delivery model.
Tier I services have just begun
to be rolled out nationwide.
These will be available
at all facilities
and are primarily
self-service in nature.
They include training, best
practices, guidance from --
guidance for staff, and forms
and resources that are available
to the inmate population.
Each facility will
collaborate with veterans
and administration staff
to ensure inmate veterans
and families of veterans
have access
to the benefits information
they need.
Tier II programs will be
rolled out later this year,
and these are outpatient
services.
These will be delivered
in a group model
and include a veteran
support group
and a veteran fitness group.
Finally, Tier III services will
be the most intense in nature
and will include piloting --
will include the piloting
of a unit-based residential
program using a therapeutic
community model.
We look forward to collaborating
with many of you as we roll
out these services nationwide.
Today, it is my honor
and pleasure
to announce the National
Institute
of Corrections Publication
entitled "Barracks Behind Bars".
In veteran-specific
housing units,
veterans help veterans
help themselves.
This publication tells
the stories of both --
of both some forward-thinking
sheriffs
who have instituted
veteran-specific housing units
in their jails and from
some of the inmates
who have benefitted
from these programs.
We are seeing a number of
these housing units, dorms,
or pods for veterans being
implemented across the country.
This publication is designed
to serve as a resource
for the field as
jurisdictions consider
veteran-specific programming.
Another great resource of this
publication is the sequential
intercept model that was adapted
to the justice-involved
veteran population.
As you can see, each decision
point provides resources
and represents an
opportunity to intervene
at the lowest level possible
to minimize the collateral
consequences
of a veteran getting more deeply
involved in the justice system.
Today, you will hear from
some of the folks featured
in the publication,
including our next speaker,
Sheriff Peter Koutoujian, from
Middlesex County, Massachusetts.
He is the -- he is serving
his second elected term
in the county with a population
of almost 6.1 million citizens,
the largest county
in Massachusetts,
and if I'm not mistaken,
in all of New England.
His focus has been developing
a series of initiatives aimed
at increasing public confidence,
providing a safer working
environment for staff,
and improving the lives of
those in the county's custody,
including in 2016, the
creation of the HUMV Program,
a housing unit for
military veterans.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Sheriff Peter Koutoujian.
[ Applause ]
>> Peter Koutoujian:
Good afternoon.
>> Audience: Good afternoon.
>> Peter Koutoujian: I want to
begin by thanking Director Lloyd
and the Library of Congress.
A number of us had
a tour this morning.
This is truly an
amazing building
that is probably not
nearly as appreciated --
I know is not nearly as
appreciated as it should be,
and I appreciate it to a
much larger degree now,
and I thank you for
hosting today's event.
To Steven Amos and Greg Crawford
from the National Institute
of Corrections, Steve
and his team and Greg
at the NIC are helping agencies
like mine and many that are here
in this room that are
watching right now
to innovate our constant
sources of support and knowledge
for sheriffs across the country.
And to Assistant Director Lara,
thank you for that kind
introduction, and you --
I know you were afraid
of my name,
and I say you did really well.
So thank you very
much for that, Sir.
I am truly honored -- I
mean this quite sincerely --
to be here among such a
distinguished group of leaders
from across the country, from
Cain County in Washington State
to San Francisco to
Orange County in Florida
to Cuyahoga County in Ohio,
New York, Texas, and elsewhere.
And on behalf of all of us here
and my Middlesex
Sheriff's Office,
to all that have
served our country,
I say thank you for
your service.
While I did not serve
in the military,
my family has a history
of service
that has always impacted me.
My grandparents came
to this country
to flee the Armenian genocide.
They sought refuge
and opportunity
in this country,
and they found it.
Three of their sons
wore the uniform,
including my Uncle Jack,
who went on to become the
Veterans Service Agent
in my hometown of
Waltham, Massachusetts.
My Uncle Arson, who died in
an accident while serving
in the Philippines
at the age of 19.
My grandmother, who could
barely speak English,
was perhaps not technically,
but for all intents
and purposes a gold-star mother
in the loss of her young son.
And yet, my grandparents
loved this country
and everything it afforded
us, the truest of patriots.
And I can just take a
moment to just think
that how proud they
would be to know
that their grandson was
speaking at the Library
of Congress as well, right?
It was that appreciation for
their service that made me want
to do better for
incarcerated veterans.
After becoming sheriff
in 2011, I discovered
that we were lacking in
verified demographic information
on veterans.
At the time, the only way we
knew if someone was a veteran,
if they told us they
were a veteran.
And so, when we spoke
about the problem
of incarcerated military
veterans across this country,
we really didn't have an
idea truly about the scope
of this problem because we
didn't have verified numbers
anywhere across this country.
This was incredibly ineffective,
and we knew that
we would miss folks
because sometimes we wouldn't
know that they were in there
or as they were coming closer to
release, they would let us know,
but by then it was too late
to give them the proper
programming while inside
or the proper handoff to the
supports that they needed.
We later learned
that the reasons
that many were not
identifying themselves,
they were afraid
of losing benefits.
Some didn't realize they
were qualified as a veteran.
For some, it was either
stigma or shame at having been
at a place of incarceration.
I knew there was a lot
more we could be doing
to improve the lives
of these individuals
and their families
-- and their families
and became personally
committed to this endeavor.
It was at that point we
started speaking to the VA
about how we could better
identify veterans, and it began
with a launch of the Veterans
Reentry Search Service,
or VRSS, developed by the VA.
The system allowed us to
match our lists of those
in our custody against
the federal databases.
And on day one, we had
19 men in our facility
who had self-identified at
having served this country.
But VRSS immediately told us
that that number was wrong.
We had another 44 in
our care, custody,
and control that we
didn't know about,
bring out total number to 63.
In fact, two-thirds
more that we knew
about were serving time with us.
In this instant, we learned
that we had tripled the number
of our veterans in our
custody, and that's why VRSS is
such a critical tool and
one I should be utilized --
I believe should be utilized
by every correctional
facility across this country.
That discovery eventually led to
the creation of the Housing Unit
for Military Veterans, or
HUMV, designed in collaboration
with administrators and staff
and the incarcerated
veterans themselves.
The unit was opened
in January of '16.
It's been open for just about
2 1/2 years, and it was named
by the veterans themselves.
Ours is not the first, and it
certainly won't be the last,
unit designed for
veterans suffering
from so many ailments,
including PTSD.
Because sheriffs and other
correctional leaders from Albany
to Arizona to recognize
specially tailored programming
for targeted population
works, a unique population,
a unique solution,
unique results.
In veterans' units
in particularly work
so much more effectively
for a number of reasons.
One, because of the staffs of
the officers, the volunteers
and the programmatic staff who
are specially trained to work
with veterans, the fact that
there are community resources
that can transition
to post release
to continue the treatment,
including the VA
any many nonprofits,
and most importantly, because
of the veterans themselves,
their own drive,
their own change.
In Middlesex, we found
that the simple act
of housing the veterans
together opened new doors
for treatment and
rehabilitation.
The men who have gone through
our HUMV have told us that being
out of the general population
and among other veterans allow
them to let their guard down,
show them that they're not
alone, because they felt
so isolated and alone
before, and allow them to open
up about their trauma
and other issues that led
to their incarceration,
making it a truly
therapeutic community.
In fact, it was said that it
was very much like being back
in the service, where
in other parts
of the correctional facility,
you had to watch your back,
and in this unit, you knew that
you had someone at your back,
and you had someone at your
left, and you had someone
at your right, and all you
needed to do was look forward.
In our unit, it didn't
matter whether you had served
in Vietnam or Enduring Freedom,
whether you had spent a year
on a submarine, you
were involved in combat,
or you served stateside,
or you were discharged
honorably or not.
And in some instances,
the issues that led
to a less-than-honorable
discharge are the very same
reasons that led to our
incarceration as well.
If you swore an oath and were
willing to protect our freedom,
we will consider
you for our program.
Our experience is not that much
different from our colleagues
around the nation, many of
whom are here today and spoke
with such passion and
knowledge and expertise.
The work that keeps happening
in these units is changing lives
and changing families
and changing communities
and making our communities safer
and saving our communities
money, all at the same time.
You can see in the data our own
snapshot pegged our recidivism
at just 5% for all those that
spent a minimum of 30 days
in our custody over two
and a half years, 5%.
Not only that, we have a
parole rate of about 95%.
We had a number of
revising roles,
meaning that the sentence
given was actually lessened
by the courts themselves.
We had a number of
men that were sent --
that were able to remain in
our unit instead of going
to the state prison
system because of the work
that we had done with them
and the believe in the courts
in our program, and
countless referrals
to veterans' treatment courts.
That's consistent with
other programs like Albany
and San Francisco, who had
publicly reported other
single-digit recidivism rates.
So this is not something
that is unique to Middlesex.
It is happening across
this country.
And more importantly, you can
hear it in the voices and see it
in the stories of the veterans
themselves, veterans like Mike,
who because of his participation
in one of these programs
and our program was able
to get a revisor revoke
and get out much earlier.
I was walking at a Labor Day
parade waving at the people
in the sides of the parade,
and suddenly out of the corner,
as I walked by one
section up on a hill,
I just could hear someone
yell out, "Humvee."
And as I looked over, I saw a
man sitting there by a woman
on the hill with his thumb up.
And I ran -- thumb --
giving me a thumbs up.
I ran up and it was Mike and he
was doing fabulously well and
yet we had allowed
him this opportunity.
Or John, who was two inches
short of killing himself
with a shotgun as
he said if he was --
if he had another two
inches of length in his arm,
he would have been dead.
Came to our facility and
progressed so significantly
that at one point, he was free
to leave on a parole to a bed
that parole was providing
for him,
but a bed that we were
going to provide him
through Veterans
Affairs was not going
to be available for
another month.
By God, he stayed with us
for another month in a place
of incarceration because he
knew he had a bed and a facility
that would be fitting
for his treatment
and we had a bed following that
for the treatment of his PTSD.
He stayed in jail an extra
month in this program.
These are the stories
that you hear.
Last year, the Washington
Examiner asked Pinal County
Sheriff Mark Lamb about the
idea of veteran's units popping
up across the country.
Mark Lamb is a border sheriff.
He is as true cowboy.
He's a pretty amazing man
and a pretty amazing sheriff.
In that, he talked about a visit
he made to our facility just
to learn what we were doing
because he liked the idea.
And this is a quote
from that newspaper.
It's kind of funny because we're
like the odd couple,
said Sheriff Lamb.
"He's a Democrat, liberal
from Massachusetts" --
I'm not sure that was
meant in the most fond way
down in Arizona -- "and I'm a
conservative, cowboy sheriff
out of Arizona, but
together, as sheriffs,
it shows how we work
together across this country."
With these initiatives, we are
showing that veterans that,
while they are being held
accountable for their actions,
we also honor their service,
and as it is said in bridge
of the military, we will
leave no man behind.
We show them that we will
not leave them behind.
Now, it's my honor to
introduce James Wright.
I will speak from a summary
of his summarized summary
because his accomplishments
are so significant,
it is really hard to get
them down on one page.
Mr. Write joined the Marine
Corps at age 17 in 1957.
He served three years and
then became the first member
of his family to
graduate from college.
He went on to earn a
PhD in American History
and joined the faculty at
Dartmouth College in 1969.
He served from 1998 to 2009
as the president of Dartmouth
and for the last 14 years,
he has been working
to support veterans.
He has been recognized for this
engagement by the secretary
of the army, the commandant
of the Marine Corps
and the commander in chief of
the Veterans of Foreign Wars.
He also has returned to his work
as a historian, publishing books
that focus on those who serve.
Those who Have Borne the Battle:
a History of Americas Wars
and those who Fought
them in 2012.
And during Vietnam, an American
Generation and its War in 2017.
It is my great honor to
introduce James Wright.
[ Applause ]
>> James Wright: Thank you,
Sheriff, you're very kind.
And I certainly want to add,
I know on behalf of everyone
in this room, a salute to
you for your own creative
and effective leadership
in support of veterans.
It's really quite
impressive what you've done
in Middlesex County.
I'm pleased to be here to have
a chance to join Karen Lloyd,
Frank Lara on this program.
I thank them for their service
and for their continuing work
on behalf of veterans.
I applaud the commitment
of the Bureau of Prisons
and the National Institute of
Corrections to veterans issues
and I commend the report
that Bernie Edelman
of Vietnam Veterans of America
and that organization's
Incarcerated Veteran's Committee
have done.
I look forward to the panel,
chaired by Jonathan Elias
with his special commitment to
telling the stories of veterans.
It is an impressive group of
panelists who daily engage
and work to resolve
these issues.
My special thanks to Bernie
Edelman and to Greg Crawford
for their service and for
their lifetime commitment
to serving those who served.
They have made a
difference and they're not
yet finished making
a difference.
Greg, thank you for all
you've done to help organize
and pull together this program.
I also want to acknowledge
our hosts here today,
the Library of Congress.
My personal thanks
to Karen Lloyd
and the Veterans
History Project.
This is a very important
program.
In my book and during Vietnam,
I acknowledge how
valuable they were
in providing personal
experiences
that enrich my account of those
who have fought in Vietnam.
Special thanks to Megan Harris
of this project for
all of her help.
Let me do a brief
personal account
because I think some parts of
it are relevant to the subject
that we're engaged in today.
In the summer of 2005,
I made my first visit
to Bethesda Naval Hospital.
The previous November, I had
been very moved and troubled
by the Battle of
Fallujah and Iraq.
I thought about it a lot then.
These were kids who
were the same age I was
when I was in the Marines.
These were the same age
of students that I saw
on the campus of Dartmouth,
indeed the son of friends
of ours and across the river
in Vermont had been killed
in Fallujah, a local Marine.
And I thought I wanted to
reach out in some way to those
who were serving and a good
friend, a retired marine, said,
"Why don't you go down to
Bethesda Hospital and visit
with the Marines there?"
I did in the summer of
2005 and since then,
I've been to Bethesda,
Walter Reed over 30 times
to visit with veterans.
I haven't been there
for a few years.
There are not as many.
The wounded veterans pipeline
has slowed significantly.
When I would go to the
hospital on my pattern,
it was always the same.
I would go bed-to-bed
and I would ask the
patient what happened.
And, you know, I never once
encountered anyone and you --
those of you who
know Walter Reed know
that these were the
most seriously injured
and wounded in most cases.
I never had anyone balk at
telling me what had happened.
And then, I would engage
them in a conversation
about their future - about
what they hoped to do
and I kept reminding them,
"You have a great
future ahead of you.
Let's think about
what you might do."
And I would ask them about
their own educational background
and plans.
And I would try to
encourage them
to continue their education.
I assured them that that already
demonstrated their discipline,
their commitment to
serving and now they needed
to prepare themselves for
the rest of their lives.
They still had so much to do --
so much more that
they could contribute.
I was able to set up an
educational counseling program
with the American
Council on Education
at Walter Reed Bethesda.
And I went out and
raised the money
to get funded --
to get it started.
And nearly 12 years
later, it is still in place
at Walter Reed now under
the Semper Fi Funds [assumed
spelling] organizationally.
A few years after that,
I was able to work
with Senators Jim Webb, and
John Warner, and Chuck Hagle
on the post-9/11 GI bill.
We had a meeting over at
the Senate office building
in February of 2008.
And I encouraged them
to be sure to include
in that legislation
something that ended
up being called the
Yellow Ribbon Program
because that provided an
opportunity for private schools
to contribute money of their
own to match that of the VA
to make certain that private
schools were an option
for these veterans.
And last year, the Congress
with bipartisan anonymity
approved an extension
and expansion of
that legislation.
It was very important and I
think everyone needs to know --
everyone needs to recognize --
that legislation such as this --
legislation such as the G.I.
bill, this is not a "Thank you
for your service" gratuity.
It may provide an
incentive to serve.
That would be good.
It may provide immediately a
fully deserved acknowledgement
of having done so
-- enabling veterans
in their transitions
back to civilian life.
But it is also an investment
in the future of this Republic.
What a resource these
veterans can provide
if we can enable them,
and encourage them,
and provide them the
opportunity to pursue it.
The ranks of the American
military today are filled
with volunteers.
They do not represent the
nation demographically.
They tend to be more
rural than urban,
more heartland than coastal.
They're largely from blue
collar middle class backgrounds
and they tend disproportionately
to come from military families.
They constitute less than
one percent of the population
and these 21st Century wars
are the first extended wars
in American History with no
designated tax to help pay
for the wars and no
service requirement
for citizens of this country.
So, much for George Washington's
reminder that it is necessary
to go to -- if it is
necessary to go to war,
all citizens should report
this with their treasure
and with their service.
Not anymore, not for these wars.
These veterans can come home and
spend a good part of the rest
of their lives helping to
pay off the debt of the wars
in which they thought
and the vast majority
of us go on with our lives.
Those who serve in these 21st
Century wars are the best
educated of Americans
to serve in any war.
They are better educated than
their age group as a whole.
The Armed Forces expect at
least a high school education
and that's a good,
positive step.
But, you know, we all know
unfortunately a high school
education is insufficient
in this modern economy.
The recent pattern of veterans
having higher unemployment rates
than non-veterans has
been largely the result
of their educational background
rather than a negative judgment
on their military service.
The parents and the grandparents
of the current veterans came
home from World War II, Korea,
Vietnam and if they
did not use the G.I.
bill to pursue an education,
they could pretty much count
on getting some good jobs at a
local factory, a mill or a mine.
And they could really
count on knowing
that if they worked hard,
they could probably have
that job until they retired.
And then, when they did retire,
they would have some
pension plan to help them.
Let's face it.
Those opportunities are
far more limited today
and there is far less likelihood
of that lifetime security.
The Post 9/11 G.I.
bill offers them an opportunity
to set a course for
their future.
But, you know, I learned
early on in my conversations
that while it is essential to
provide the financial support
for veterans to continue their
education, there was a prior --
an often more difficult
counseling need and this was
to encourage them to
do this, to assure them
that they could do this.
While nearly all of those who've
joined the voluntary military
may be high school graduates,
most of them did not take
college preparatory courses.
They probably have not taken
standardized ACT or SAT exams.
They often feel unprepared
for higher education and some
of them may not be ready.
But I have no doubt that
they all can be ready.
Counseling and convincing
them of this is essential
as is follow-up support
to encourage them
to pursue and to succeed.
You see, we have
a national need --
an obligation to try to
encourage all students
who have never been encouraged.
They can do this.
And this is where those
young men and women
with military experience
can draw
on some greater self-confidence
if we can remind them
why they should have this
greater self-confidence.
You know, there's another part
of the American military
experience --
of any military experience
that we need to understand.
All of the children in
this country really --
human beings across the
world learn as infants
to remember two pretty
constant things.
One is to lookout
for themselves.
Avoid any threatening risks.
Don't go there.
Don't touch that.
Look carefully.
Be cautious.
And they're also told
not to harm others
and the latter is more
than parental guidance
as it is emphasized under threat
of law, as well as moral code,
and religious teachers
teachings.
Do not bring harm
to other people.
Think of a very small
fraction of our citizens
in their late teens
and early twenties.
When they're mobilized
for war --
[ Coughing ]
-- they're told they have
to suppress these fundamental
instincts and principles
when the situation demands.
They must be willing to put
themselves in harm's way
without question or
without hesitation.
[ Coughing ]
"Go there and do it."
They go and do.
They don't stop and
reflect on it.
"This looks dangerous."
That's not their job.
They're told to go.
And they must be willing
to bring harm to others --
lethal harm without any
delay, any opportunity
for moral reflection,
"Should I be doing this?"
This is their assignment.
Now when they return to civilian
life, they are told to return
to their first rules --
to forget that which they
have just learned and to wipe
from their memory
contrary experiences.
Obviously, in each of these
instances, this is impossible.
The vast majority of
combat veterans do return
to civilian lives successfully,
but they never forget
that experience that they had.
It's a difficult transition.
Some do not return as
successfully as others.
And indeed, some of
this group are a matter
for our focus today.
We need to know the
experience of war from those
who were there before we can
begin to understand it --
to know how profound
this experience is,
how contrary it is to everything
they've been taught and learned.
As a Vietnam veteran,
army combat photographer,
a friend Dick [inaudible]
recently described it.
"They risk their lives.
They face terror.
They lose buddies in battles
and then they come home
where they have to square what
they had to do as warriors
with what they are now expected
to do that they are home.
It isn't easy."
Veterans who are in prison for
committing a crime face many
of the same problems
that non-veterans face
in transitioning back
to civilian life
following their release --
problems of employment,
of acceptance,
of reentering American society
while encountering suspicion
at every turn.
And finally, of avoiding
recidivism --
this path is harder to avoid if
individuals encounter a society
that has little confidence
and a good outcome.
These problems may be
compounded for veterans
who have been released.
They confront dual and
reinforcing stereotypes.
The current Ban the
Box initiative
to encourage perspective
employers
and college admissions
applications
to discontinue asking questions
about criminal convictions
is an interesting effort.
It's reminiscent to me of
Vietnam veterans in the 1970's
who came home and didn't
acknowledge their military
service on job applications
because they thought
this was something
that would be far
better for them
if their employer didn't have
to say, "Were you a veteran?
Were you at [inaudible]?"
and ask some of the most foolish
questions you could imagine.
We've, we've come a
great distance medically
since posttraumatic stress
disorder was recognized
as a clinical disorder, but
that journey is not over,
and the distance
remains even greater
in accomplishing
social acceptance
of this mental health condition.
The mental, the medical
and the legal recognition
of PTSD has been so important.
We discuss is more openly now.
But you know I also
worry that this talking
about it more openly ironically
has buttressed another cruel
stereotype, that of the
socially unhinged veteran.
The Vietnam veterans
in the 1970's came
straight into this headwind.
And they encountered
movies such as Taxi Driver
and Apocalypse Now,
which deranged psychotic
veterans emerged.
The 1970's were not kind
to veterans coming back
from an unpopular war.
In the 1970's on one episode
of the popular television
show Kojak,
Telly Savalas confronted
a series
of brutal homicides
in Manhattan.
He told one of his
detectives to find
out if there were
any Vietnam veterans
in the neighborhood
of the crimes.
Think of this.
Are there any Vietnam
veterans there?
PTSD is a companion of
all wars, redevises,
but this was not
even done diagnosed
as a clinical condition
until 1979.
Before that, veterans with
problems were categorized
as suffering from
the Vietnam syndrome,
as if it were an
isolated condition of what
so many other veterans thought
of as this whining hippy group
coming back from Vietnam.
World War II veterans, their
parents' generation told them
to grow up and get over it.
They said we did.
But of course, not
all of them did.
It was called combat
fatigue or shell shock then.
The Vietnam veterans spoke of
nightmares becoming day-mares.
One said to me, if
those other people had
to spend just one night inside
my nightmares they would fall
to the floor with
tears in their eyes.
But you know these
veterans endured
and they have contributed so
much to our national life.
One thing we've learned is
that veterans will speak
about their experiences
more candidly and more,
more personally with
other veterans.
Some of the best counseling
sessions involve a group
of veterans sharing
their stories
and encouraging one another.
If post-911 veterans
have not had to contend
with the same nasty degrading
stereotypes in popular culture,
they still have too often to
encounter wisps of the fear
and prejudice that remain.
And here they're reinforcing
fear and prejudice and suspicion
that confronts the ones
where former convicts
and veterans can be
even harder to escape.
If this is their
difficult assignment,
I have confidence in them.
But our society has
a role as well.
We still need to thank them for
their service and recognize this
as not a condescending
throw-away gratuity.
They need a hand, not a
handout, they need a hand.
We need to recognize what
they did on our behalf,
even if they have
stumbled since.
They have much to offer.
You know Americans today
do juggle their views
of the current generation
of veterans.
They applaud them when
they're introduced at events.
They call them all heroes.
And yet they're also
a little bit uneasy
around them sometimes.
We all need to know them better.
We need to understand
who they are,
what they've endured,
what they want to do.
These veterans have worked
effectively with others
of different backgrounds.
They've assumed responsibility
and accountability.
They function in
complex organizations
and in an advanced
technological environment,
and they've confronted dangerous
situations while respecting
people of different cultures.
They have learned
discipline and restrained
in self-confidence
and tolerance.
They have observed, and
they have themselves offered
sacrifice for a greater good.
I'm impressed by the options
that sheriffs and wardens
such as those speaking
here today.
Officers such as
Sheriff Peter Koutoujian
and his Middlesex County team.
Captain Malik Muhammad of
Orange County, Florida.
Ron Perez of the San
Francisco Sheriff's Department
that have created
to help veterans.
Judge Michael Jackson
and his initiative
in providing veterans
courts, Semper Fi Judge
and thank you for
what you've done.
Their counseling and the
specialized living unit's
that some have developed
allow veterans to connect
with each other, remember they
are more comfortable talking
to each other.
It's an essential step towards
their reconnecting with society
but that's the society
that sent them to war.
The report which
is released today,
and this gathering addressed the
value of programs such as these,
these veterans have
met their obligation,
now we have an obligation
to reach out to them.
They will benefit from
our support of course.
As we all have already
greatly benefited
from all that they have done.
And we and our society will
be the better if we are able
to help them to succeed.
It is truly a win-win.
We are all ahead if we
can help them to succeed.
Maybe it's too much
delayed, but now we need
to say delayed reciprocal
we've got your back,
now we want to help you.
I'm going to hand off the stage
to our moderator,
Jonathan Elias.
Mr. Elias is an award-winning
journalist and the host
of WJLA's Salute to Veterans.
He's an instructor at the Army
War College, and he's passionate
about veterans' issues.
Before that, I believe we
have a brief video message
from Evan Simone, an attorney
at the Harvard Law
School's Veteran's Law
and Disability Benefit's Office.
Thank you for participating
in this program today.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
>> Evan Simone: Hello.
My name is Evan Simone.
I'm an attorney here at
Harvard's Veteran's Legal Clinic
where my main duty is to
find underserved veterans
in the community and assist
them with legal issues.
Today the National Institute
of Corrections has recognized
that veterans' treatment
courts are one method
of assisting veterans who
are in conflict with the law.
However, it's important to
realize that only a fraction
of veterans are eligible for
veterans treatments courts.
Many of them will not
be able to participate
in diversionary document
or alternatives
to sentencing and confinement.
NIC has focused on this
phenomenon of veterans' dorms,
sometimes they're called pods,
sometimes they're unit's,
sometimes they're
veterans blocks.
What these are our reserved
spaces for veterans to live
and interact with one another
when they're confined
in prisons or jails.
And NIC has, has illuminated
that these programs lead
to many pathways to
positive intervention.
These programs draw on the
veterans' sense of pride,
and they adhere to values
that they still have
embedded in their [inaudible].
These programs promote
responsibility for others
in much the same way that
these veterans work together
in military units.
These are counterparts to
veterans' treatment courts.
Corrections professionals who
are responsible for oversight
of inmates more often
than not attest
that these specialized unit's
for veterans promote safety
and good order in
institutional settings.
And while careful
consideration should be given
to the specific format for a
program, it's vital to realize
that most correctional
institutions already have the
essential elements to put
these programs in place.
We're talking about the
space to put veterans
in proximity to one another.
We're talking about
corrections professionals
who themselves have
military experience.
We're talking about the
paint to put up slogans
and reminders of
military service.
We're talking about time.
The commodity of time to
reflect deeply on the manner
in which military service has
affected veterans' behavior.
And we're also talking about the
time to seek important benefit's
that will help in the future.
I'd like to thank those who
serve this country in uniform,
and especially I'd like to thank
those who continue to serve
by helping justice involved
veterans reintegrate
into our communities
as productive
and restored citizens.
[ Music ]
>> Jonathan Elias:
Well good afternoon.
That's all you got really?
We need a seventh inning
stretch around here?
I became involved with
the military going
on two decades now.
And early on I was
recognizing returning Purple
Heart recipients.
I just thought for me I
wanted to say something
because I knew a lot of friends
of mine that were veterans,
and maybe they got beat
up or bruised or scarred.
And I noticed that
the spirit was intact.
Their bodies may have been
bruised but their spirit,
and I wanted to celebrate
that spirit.
And I'll never forgot
this one time,
we would just have gatherings
of just strangers come together
and say, thank you for your
service and welcome home,
because the transition
from military
to civilian is very difficult.
And I had a 23-year-old core man
come up to me, good looking kid,
you know, and he looked
buttoned down on the outside.
And he said, you know
why are you doing this?
And all of a sudden,
he started to tremble
and shake and started to cry.
And then he just gave me this
hug and it was like holding
like one of my little kids
after they'd gotten scolded
where they're just shaking.
And I just sat there
and held this kid
and we just talked for a while.
And he asked me again,
why are you doing this?
And I said, well
because everybody should.
And then it got me introduced
to the whole idea of what PTSD,
this window dressing
of this buttoned down,
good-looking kid
was really a veneer
to something much more painful
and something much more deep.
And we -- when we spent time
talking, he explained to me
that war is its own language.
And that the language of war
is one where there is pain.
When you're having a bad day,
maybe you get scolded at work
and you get the boo-boo lip
because your boss didn't
like something you did.
When they have a bad day,
they've gone through the birth
of a child, sitting in
some fob in Afghanistan.
You have a bad day,
maybe you got a ticket
on your way to work.
When they have a bad day, they
step on something that goes boom
and their lives are
forever changed
because they're losing
their legs or their arms,
their ability to do anything.
Their language of war is so
impossible for us to speak,
if you've not walked or marched
in a battlefield with brothers
and sisters at your side, and
suffered the loss of somebody,
it's impossible for you to get
your head around that language.
And then they come home.
And that language is
still fresh in their mind.
That's the language they speak.
And yet here they are
on our streets trying
to function as normal citizens.
It's a very difficult
transition.
It used to frustrate me that the
military didn't do a better job
of transitioning.
But as was explained to
me by a marine colonel
who is a very good friend, and
he's incredibly smart, he said,
how do we transition
somebody from learning
in introducing the language
of war, and then going
to a civilian language
once again?
So, it's incumbent upon
all of us given the fact
that these are people who
have given our lives for us,
they have selflessly
decided to sign up
and go serve a greater
purpose than themselves,
they're doing it for country.
The least we can do
is pay them back.
So, when he said to me, you
know, why are doing this?
And I said, everybody should.
Well let me just
introduce to something.
There's 41,000 plus agencies,
nonprofit's out there,
that are doing things to help
better the lives of veterans.
In addition to that, we have
leaders within our community
that are sitting off to my left
here that are trying to help
when they come back, and
they suffer from PTSD they,
all of them have scars.
Those heal.
The wounds never heal.
The wounds stay with
them forever.
Some will be able to adapt
and get back into the light,
and just try and forget it
and put it in their past.
And others make bad
decisions along the way
and they find themselves
in the courts
as we discussed last year,
and when it gets worse,
they find themselves
incarcerated.
So, do we owe them something
when they find themselves
making a bad decision,
getting incarcerated?
You bet we do.
I think everybody in
America, if you ask them,
listen these are people that
went off and fought for you.
Do we owe them something?
Yes. And as Mr. Wright
said, it is not a hand
out that they're looking for.
None of them would take it.
A hand up is really all
they're looking for,
just to get back on their feet.
What I'd like to do with our
panel is I'm going to ask them
if they could, briefly,
last year went a little crazy
we got ten-minute dissertations.
I just want 60 seconds,
please introduce yourself
and tell us what it is you are
doing right now, in 60 seconds,
and then we'll start
the conversation.
>> Greg Crawford:
Thank you Jonathan.
My name is Greg Crawford,
I'm with the National
Institute of Corrections.
I'm going to say some
thank yous to the group.
I want to thank the Library
of Congress and Karen Lloyd
and Andrew Hubert for again
bringing us back this year.
I do want to thank those
that have served our country
in uniform, and also those
that continue to serve,
whether you're a law enforcement
officer or correctional officer
at a jail or a prison,
or a probation officer
or somebody working
at a veterans court,
thank you for continuing
to serve,
and also the veteran
peer mentors.
I served in the Air Force,
but it did shape my life.
It helped create
structure and discipline
which was much needed,
just ask my father
and my mother at the time.
But it helped also
lead me into working
in the criminal justice system.
I started working
in mental health.
I worked three years
in mental health
and it shaped my philosophy
to working with people.
You can't treat a piece
of the person you have
to treat the entire person and
that's why I think these types
of programs, veterans'
courts and programs
and local housing units for
jails work so effectively,
is because you're, you're
treating all of the person.
I want to thank James Wright
for being here today for giving
such a wonderful
key note speech.
Peter Koutoujian, Sheriff
Koutoujian thank you
for being here today.
And also, Frank Lara
whose stepped
in for Mark Inch, Director Inch.
Even though he is not here
today I want to thank him,
because quite frankly without
his support we would not be here
today, and we would
not be releasing this
publication today.
So, if you're listening,
thank you.
I also want to thank
the National State
of Corrections leadership for
supporting veterans' initiatives
and for being here today.
We started with veterans'
treatments courts,
a second chance for
vets who lost their way,
that's why we were
kind of here last year
and this year we're
releasing another publication
and I'm honored to pass it
off to my colleague here,
Bernie Edelman who offered
both of these publications.
Bernie.
>> Bernie Edelman: Let's
see if I can do this in 59.
I'm [inaudible] Brooklyn,
graduated college, got drafted,
spent most of 1970 in
Vietnam, that changed my life.
I was not a combatant, I
was a broadcast specialist,
combat correspondent.
Spent a lot of time in a
hospital, spent a lot of time
with a civil affairs unit.
Still changed my life.
Came back, got a career,
certain things never left me.
Participated in a
Vietnam art show,
brought it to New York
City, which is my hometown,
and I was named by
Major Koch to serve
in the New York Vietnam
Veterans Memorial Commission.
As a result of the
memorial we did,
we did the book Dear America:
Letters Signed from Vietnam.
Became an HBO documentary
of the same name.
Since then, I became
the Mayor's Office
of Veterans Affairs Director
under Ed, first public health,
public official to put his
money where his mouth was
when it dealt with
Vietnam Veterans.
I've been down here
for 15 years now
with Vietnam Veterans
of America.
Which is one of the
most activists
of all the veterans
service organizations.
I'm Deputy Director for
Policy and Government Affairs.
Technically though,
I'm a lobbyist.
Thank you.
>> Michael Jackson: My
name is Michael Jackson,
I'm from the Cleveland
area, and I'm a judge
at [inaudible] County
[inaudible] court.
I ran as a veteran and
was the only veteran,
am presently the only
veteran on our bench.
In the Vietnam War after my
college graduation I joined the
Marine Corps and was a first
lieutenant commanding a company
and a second lieutenant
commanding a platoon.
Came back, went to law
school, married the love
of my life who is here today.
And practiced law and decided I
wanted to be a judge at the end
of my career and I wanted
to start a veterans'
treatment court.
Three years ago, we had
one veteran and now we have
over 100 veterans in my court.
And we started a jail pod
connecting our veterans court
with those in the county
jail and look forward
to exchanging some of
those views this afternoon.
>> Malik Muhammad: Good
afternoon I'm Malik Muhammad
from Orlando, Florida.
I'm currently employed
by the Orange County Corrections
Department and I've been there
for the last 19 years.
I am retired military, I
retired in January of this year.
The first six years of my
military career was spent
on active duty, and
the remainder was spent
as a reservist out
of Orlando, Florida.
And on behalf of my
chief Corinda Riley
and our Mayor Theresa
Jacobs I bring you greetings
from Orange County
Corrections Department.
>> Ron Perez: I guess it's me.
I'm Ron Perez, I
too was drafted.
I'm a Vietnam veteran.
I was drafted shortly after
high school, served in Vietnam
from August 1, 1967
till August 1968.
1975 I went into the San
Francisco county jail,
and I've been there ever since,
working for the sheriff
department
in their prisoner services
division, developing
and creating programs.
I retired from the sheriff's
department approximately 2008.
Shortly thereafter, they
contacted me and said, "Ron,
remember that Veteran's Program
you said we should always start?
Well, we're going to do it."
So I came back on a consulting
basis and did development
and implementation
of the program.
We started out program in 2010,
2013 because we had showed we
had a significant population,
the veteran's court started.
Our program is called COVER.
COVER stands for Community of
Veterans Engaged in Restoration.
That name was --
-- was the idea at brain trial
of our veteran service officer,
our sheriff at that time.
Loved having programs
that had little --
nice little tippets that went to
him like, sheriff work furlough,
and sheriffs work
alternatives, so when he --
and he loved restoring justice.
And when he heard
community of veterans engaged
in restoration, he loved it.
Part of the reason
it was called COVER,
the officer from veteran service
office was a retired air force
military, and you all know,
if you were in the military,
you can't leave billets
without your cover.
>> Jonathan Elias: Good
to have you out here.
If you're not familiar
with how --
is anybody in the
room not familiar
with how the correction
system works?
Good. We don't have to
waste a lot of time.
So you know when you're in the
corrections -- and I had --
my wife worked at one
of worst -- it was --
The New York Times dubbed it
the most violent institution
for youthful offenders
in the free world.
So I was really happy
when she'd [Inaudible]
after work every day, there was
[Inaudible] out in California.
And it was a absolutely
horrible place.
Very well run, and immaculate,
I mean you'd look at it
and think it was a
mall when you drove by.
But when I went in and I
took a tour, I remembered
that there were movements done
from certain sections
of populations.
They literally had to separate
the populations for fear
that they would be violence.
And they were all
pretty much high risk,
because they said
anybody between 18
and 25 was probably the
most violent, or most likely
to offend in a population.
And that's what we're talking
about with most of the veterans.
We're talking that age group.
So when they go into prison,
you would think it would be a
no-brainer, that you'd segregate
that population perhaps.
And then you say
to yourself, "Well,
why would they separate --
segregate that population?
What is it about the
veterans population
that needs segregating?"
So let's put that to the panel.
Why is it a good idea to
segregate the population
of veterans that find
themselves incarcerated?
What is it that's going to come
from that, is it productive?
Is there a chance that perhaps
you'll put them on the path?
What is the reason for
segregating that population?
Anybody, please.
>> Judge Michael E. Jackson:
Well, I think the basic reason
for doing that is that there's
something about being a veteran
that is different and separate
from those who have not served.
And to place veterans together,
you're recreating a
shared military experience.
And from my experience, it
doesn't matter if the person was
in combat or not, served
early or served late.
But that shared military
experience.
Other veterans understand.
And the veterans in our county
jail say the same thing that all
of the veterans in
the publication
that you'll have the
opportunity to read,
say in other jails throughout
the country, is that it's safer,
it's quieter, it's more
peaceful, they don't fight.
If they do, they
solve it themselves.
And they respect
each other in a way
that because they've all served.
They may not like each other,
but they do respect each other
because of that service.
And they end up helping
each other in that regard.
And for those who
have drug addictions,
or mental health addictions
or issues, particularly PTSD,
being in a quite safe place,
even if you have to be there
in jail, is much better
than the general population.
>> Greg Crawford: So I had -- I
went on a few of the site visits
for this publication, and
I just want to kind of add
to what he said, judge.
Another really good thing for
this is the efficiency of it.
One of the folks
mentioned, in king --
in Seattle, was the fact
that the VA could
come-in in one spot.
People could come into one
spot and talk to people,
rather than bounce
around the different parts
of the correctional facility.
So I think efficiency, and
having those resources all
in one spot makes
a lot of sense.
>> Ron Perez: And it also
helps your outside agencies,
and also it makes it easier
for them because they know
that they just have
to visit one facility,
and they know they can call
and check and make sure
when they're coming out to
do the intake on the veteran,
that the veteran is
there, not in court
or being moved somewhere else.
>> Jonathan Elias: Have
you spent a lot of time
with the inmates that
represents this population?
Do you get a sense
from some of them
that they should have been
some sort of intervention?
What I found from working with,
especially those who came back
with PTSD, is that
a lot of times,
they just needed a friend.
A lot of times they come back
and they feel isolated, lost,
they feel that language
that they learned overseas,
they don't speak it anymore,
nobody in their family
understands it,
so they just shut down.
Is that often times
what you find?
>> Ron Perez: We still have
a significant population
of Vietnam air veterans
in our jails.
And quite often, very often,
they'll say this
is what I needed
when I came home from veteran.
Something like this I would
not have spent my entire life
in the criminal justice system.
>> Captain Malik Muhammad:
And I've heard similar stories
in Orange County, we have
veterans that talk about,
"If these programs
would have been
around when they
first got out, maybe,
just maybe they would
not have ended
up in the criminal
justice system."
So again, it's a benefit
of having them there,
and I also believe
it starts to process.
When you have those
veterans together.
One of the things the military
taught us was comradery
and the espirit de corps.
So by placing all these guys
in one dedicated housing unit,
you start that treatment
process for recovery.
>> Jonathan Elias: Let's talk
about resource for a second,
'cause everybody
is so keenly aware
that everything cost money.
This doesn't strike
me as any program,
like I know the middle
six, sheriff was talking
about the kinds of
things that they've done.
This is just redirecting,
as opposed to trying
to acquire more money
or a budget
to put something together.
This is just about
redirecting resources, right?
This isn't something that
could be cost prohibitive.
>> Ron Perez: For us in San
Francisco, we're extremely lucky
because we've had sheriffs
for the last thirty years
that have concentrated on the
development of re-entry services
for all prisoners in the jail.
So, we were able
to tap into a lot
of already developed programs,
tailor them specifically
for veterans.
>> Jonathan Elias: And if you
can do it in San Francisco
with no extra money, then
it can be done anywhere.
>> Ron Perez: That's correct.
>> Jonathan Elias: Let me
ask you the same question.
Is this something you're
finding that you can do by just,
maybe talking to few folks,
redirecting some assets
and not necessarily putting
more on the budget line?
>> Captain Malik Muhammad:
We did exactly the same
thing down in Orlando.
We were able to start our unit
without using any addition
or physical resources, because
we had a physical plan --
space available.
And we had a good
program in place,
it was relatively
easy transition.
So I want to let you guys know
that it's not a hard process,
and you can do it without
spending a whole lot of money.
>> Greg Crawford: And I
want to make the point
that I think the first thing you
ought to do if you're thinking
about this is identify
your population.
Find out how many people you
actually have in custody,
and you know, data will drive
a lot of your decisions, right?
>> Jonathan Elias: Judge,
do you find that to
be an effective tool?
>> Judge Michael E. Jackson:
It's exactly the same.
It was easy to convince -- in
our jurisdiction, I'm a veteran,
the sheriff is a veteran,
the deputy sheriff who was
in charge of us is a veteran.
We both came to this
idea the same time,
we just weren't working
together.
We talked to each
other and we started it
within I think sixty days
after our first meeting.
It's just reorganizing the jail,
and finding a spot
that's suitable
in the confinement facility.
Training your guards to deal
with veterans differently.
Many of the sheriff deputies
and the corrections officers
who are veterans wanted to
participate in this project,
in the county jail,
because they were veterans.
Some were upset because
they were doing it.
But by and large, most of the
veterans wanted to be involved
because they sensed that
these veterans with some help,
would be on taking the
first step towards recovery.
>> Jonathan Elias: And we'll
talk in a second about the kind
of pitfalls that you might run
into, that might be helpful
to somebody, maybe somebody
watching live and they have
like a jurisdiction out there
that they've been thinking
about it, but haven't done it.
Let's get to that in a second,
but talk to me for a second
about the characteristics
of veteran inmate,
are they a different population?
Because you have some folks
that are just chronic criminals,
life-long criminals, and
these people are not going
to be fixed or cured
of anything.
Well, when veterans come in,
do you get the sense
they've just made a mistake,
they made bad decisions,
they can be put back
on a path quickly, is it an
easy adjust or what is it?
>> Ron Perez: Veterans
seem to fit
into a jail setting rather
naturally, because of the fact
that your jails and prisons
operate some semi-militaristic,
with inspections, with
line-up's, etcetera,
with work detailed,
structure, exactly.
So a veteran coming into the
jail system can fit very easily
into that system,
and a lot times,
what we found before we
started our veterans program,
is the best workers in the
jail that were identified,
were often veterans, and
veterans who had come back
into jail, "Oh, there's Gunny,
he's going to run the kitchen."
We see that quite often.
>> Jonathan Elias: So
they feel plugged in.
They feel like they
have a purpose?
>> Ron Perez: Yep.
They can follow the
orders, they, you know,
they've got the structure,
get up at a certain time,
go off to your work
detail, come back,
here's your phone call
time, here's your meal time,
here's your nap time,
and so it makes --
it's much more easier than
the world they were living
in on the outside where
they lost that structure
and lost that comradery.
>> Greg Crawford: Just
something that Jim mentioned
in his introductory
remarks is reminding them
of the confidence
that they once had.
And I think that's an important
point that I think this kind
of programing does for veterans,
is it kind of gets their sense
of self, you know, purpose back,
and I think that
that's what it does.
It get's their confidence going.
>> Captain Malik Muhammad:
It kind of reacclimates them,
back to that military
life, because jails
and prison are traditionally a
para-military type organization.
So being in that
environment reacclimates them
to what they were
once accustomed to.
Also, by placing
them in position
to where they're working for the
jails and doing various things,
it gives them a sense of pride
and a sense of leadership.
And also, you have
that belongingness
that they often times seek.
>> Jonathan Elias: But anytime
we send somebody way to prison,
the hope is, in the
back of the minds is
that justice would be served,
that they'll learn their lesson
and they'll come
back into society.
Do you get a sense from veterans
when they do make bad decisions,
find themselves incarcerated
that they are a population
that is much higher at perhaps
going back and reacclimating
to public life by learning
something from prison?
Are they successful
as candidates coming
out of incarceration?
I don't know, I'm asking you.
>> Judge Michael E. Jackson:
Well, in many of the prison's,
particularly in Ohio, I think
it's pretty much nationwide.
The veterans in prison
have organized themselves
and they've been permitted
by prison authorities,
allowing them to do this, to
set up very similar operations
than -- as we're talking
about with the veterans
in the county jail.
So if you go to a
number of prions in Ohio,
you'll see a veterans pod there.
Some of them are even working
towards doing productive
business while in
prison, it's authorized.
And they have their
own discipline group
among themselves.
And they are transitioning
to the community
by having people come in.
In fact, one of the veteran
service organization the AMVETS,
they even have chapters
of AMVETS
or like American
Legion, VFW, in prisons.
And so they are a member
of a veterans organization.
So it's not as if it
doesn't go on there.
So hopefully when they
transition out, they'll have
that foundation that they can
recreate, and live productive
and law-abiding lives.
The connection in the jails
also is worthy of note,
when you connect with a
veteran's treatment court,
so I would get those people from
the veteran's pod in the jail,
put them in a veteran's
treatment court program,
where they have four stages
that hey have to go through.
And when they graduate, they
have the ability, we hope,
to be self-sustaining.
>> Jonathan Elias: What
kinds of mistakes are some
of these veterans making when
they come back, when they decide
to make bad decisions and
find themselves incarcerated.
Because I know we have the
court system that was setup,
we talked about last year.
Which tries to kind of intervene
and get in between some
of those veterans
that are coming back,
that have just made minor
infractions in the world
of the criminal justice system.
Some of this though, I mean,
this are very serious charges
that they probably will
never see the light of day.
>> Ron Perez: Sometimes it
can be something as simple
as not being in compliance
with their medication.
We had an individual that came
into our system, was a captain,
a rogue scholar, a
West Point graduate.
When he got out of
the military, he went
and got himself a little plot
of land in Alaska that butted
up against the forest, and
everything was fine except
when he came back to visit
family in the bay area.
And he got himself
into a situation
where he should have been
dealt with psychiatrically,
but instead wound
up being jailed.
He came to our attention,
we weren't able to get him
into cover because of
his psychiatric issues,
but we were able to get
him into veteran's court,
get him stabilized,
and it was determined
through veteran's court that
the best thing to do would be
to get him back to his
community, back into Alaska
where he had veteran
services already in place.
We were able to do that.
We had one of our veteran's
court, mentors fly back
to Alaska with them, and his
veterans court status has been
transitioned to Alaska.
He's still having difficulties,
but it was the best
place for him.
And again, he should
never have been
in the criminal justice
system, he should have been
in the mental health
system, but got caught
up in criminal justice.
But because of the
efforts of having COVER,
having veterans court, he's
not perfect, but he's stable,
and he's living day to day.
>> Jonathan Elias: Sheriff
some of your examples?
>> Captain Malik Muhammad:
I was going to say that,
just like the technical
violation that he mentioned.
Sometime I've seen them come
back for self-medicating,
if they don't take care
of the substance abuse issue
while they're in custody
and get the right treatment.
Sometimes, when times get
tough when they're realized,
they tend to self-medicate
and find themselves back
in custody due to
something as minor as,
let's say, failing a drug test.
>> Judge Michael E. Jackson:
I think all of the veteran
supreme court judges
and those involved with
helping veterans while in jail,
all recognize that there
are a number of veterans
who draw some pretty
serious charges.
And one of the things that
we have to distinguish is,
holding those -- that
induvial, veteran or not,
to be accountable
for their conduct.
The part that comes into play
that's effective for veterans is
that to the extent, we can,
we couple that with a
treatment situation.
So, I just had a case
a couple of weeks ago,
where a veteran had a flash
back, he was combat veteran,
Iraq, had a flashback,
as I mentioned,
three police officers
were injured.
None life threatening
to my knowledge.
The three officers asked for --
were given the opportunity
at sentencing
to say what they wanted to
happen to this individual.
One said, prison.
One said, judge it's up to you.
And the other said, most
definitely probation.
The person who said probation
was a combat veteran.
And he understood what was
going on with that veteran,
with regard to a flashback.
And so as a treatment
court judge, I have to make
that decision with regard
to being accountable
to that conduct,
which was serious,
but also make him
available to the services
that I think would help him.
In his situation, he's
going to be confined for up
to nine months, maybe a little
bit less if he does well.
But he's going to be in the
veteran's treatment court,
and he's going to be in the
veteran's pod, and he's going
to have access to some
treatment during those process.
>> Jonathan Elias: One
of the biggest issues,
especially with those
veterans coming back with PTSD,
especially being in the new
business we're keenly aware,
this is domestic violence, the
numbers are just astronomical.
It has to go back -- it
goes back to the language
that I was discussing earlier
about the language of war
when you come back, you don't
speak the same language.
And the language in a
relationship is much different.
There's an intimate -- an
intimacy with a relationship
of understanding another person.
But that side of
veterans, especially those
who have seen combat, or
they've been affected by war
in such a meaningful way,
that shuts down in them.
Breaking through those
communication lines,
this is one of those
opportunities,
and unfortunately
it comes to prison,
and that's what we're talking
about with this setting.
But in that setting where
you have other veterans,
they become a support group.
But it almost -- I think it
breaks everybody's heart hearing
the fact that they have
to go to prison in other
to find the support group
that ultimately can help them
on the road to recovery.
Is that right?
>> Judge Michael E.
Jackson: Absolutely.
I interviewed all 22 people
in our jail, I talked to them,
I did an interview,
before I came out here,
and all of them said essentially
the same thing that's
in our publication.
They use this as a support
group amongst themselves.
And so, they really
are helping themselves.
And one of the veterans came up
to me and said, "You now, judge,
couple of vets were bad rapping
you, and I had to talk to them."
I'm not quite sure what he
said to them, but one of them,
he said, he didn't think
the punishment was right,
and the other vet said, "Well,
you have four positive tests
for, you know, drug use.
What did you expect?"
So, they can have
that conversation.
And they can talk it out.
And whether it's right or wrong,
or whether my punishment
was too hard or too lean,
they have an avenue of talking
it out among themselves.
And they can hear other sides
and that doesn't generally go
on in the population as I think
many other sheriffs could attest
better than I.
>> Ron Perez: And I
just wanted to add,
you touched on domestic
violence.
Our program, we have
a component --
that sheriff's department had
this component quite some time
ago resolve to stop
the violence,
and anti-domestic violence,
anti-partner program.
It's been adopted -- had been
adapted, actually, by the VA
and is being provided in
San Francisco to veterans,
and on the outside,
it's called, 'At-Ease'.
We have a component in our COVER
program, we call it stand down,
but it talks -- it deals
with the male world --
belief system and violence,
and addressing that.
But it's geared toward veterans.
And I believe it's probably
the first one in the country
to be started specifically
for veterans on dealing
with domestic violence,
'cause again, that's something
that they VA, up until this
point has not been looking at.
>> Bernie Edelman: You now, it
strikes me that we feel so good
when folks come back from a tour
of duty whether it is in Iraq,
Afghanistan, or Vietnam, they
are greeted by their family,
and it is supposed to be
wonderful at least it is
in the opinion of the eyes
of people who see that.
There are an awful lot
of guys who come back,
they haven't got no family.
The family is dysfunctional.
They have been dysfunctional
for years.
Their family were the
brothers and sisters they had
in a combat situation.
All of a sudden,
they find themselves
without a support group.
They start drinking or drugging.
I know of one guy, he was
a crew chief on a medevac,
a medical evacuation helicopter.
He would slush through
blood every day
that he was in the air.
He came back, couldn't talk,
got married, couldn't talk
to his wife, upstairs of
a bar, and for10 years,
he drank himself into
oblivion every night.
He started having
flashbacks on his way to work
when he got a different job.
His life was all but stuck.
Nobody told him he had
anything wrong with him.
He knew there was
something the matter,
but he didn't know what it was.
We took a long time before
there was an intervention
and he started getting health
[inaudible] and one of that is
through the vet centers,
which were one
of the most successful
operations of the VA.
We [inaudible] of
the VA to keep that.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
So, talking about, you know,
I wish there was some way
to improve from active duty
to the VA Services,
there is a gap.
I hate that sometimes with the
first opportunity to intervene
in someone's life is involvement
with the justice system.
So, one of the things
that I am really--
this publication folks is on
housing units for local jails,
and if you think about the
continuum of criminal justice
between the community
and law enforcement,
jails and vet courts,
and prison and re-entry.
I think what is really
important,
even though this
publication focuses
on housing units it also
promotes collaboration
between entities within the
criminal justice system.
I think what is really
important for us to think
about is people are considering
implementing these programs
as partnering with other parts
of the criminal justice system
because you can not
only share resources
but you can improve outcomes
if law enforcement is talking
to the vet court and that is
something that I have seen
on the newest project
that we are working
on around law enforcement
officers responding to veterans
in crisis overseeing
a sheriff, detective,
or a detective assigned to a
vet court, and there is a link
between the housing unit, the
vet court, and the community,
and I think Judge Jackson has
done a good job of communicating
between the local jail
and his vet court.
He was instrumental
in setting that up,
but I think that that is
something that is important
to think about is not just
focusing on your own peace
but look branching out
and communicating
within your system.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
I think most who are going
to hear this has said this is
a great idea in kind of one
of those no brainers in life.
The question I have is why
wouldn't every correctional
house, whether it's a
small local jurisdiction
or even a big federal unit,
why wouldn't they
institute this kind
of program and do it right away.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
I can't really think
of a reason why they wouldn't,
but I can share with you
from experience that
when starting up,
the hardest thing
is just getting buy
in from the stakeholders
that currently work there,
the public, and your
administration.
Those are kind of your hurdles
when you are initially trying
to start a program and once
you get those accomplished
or over those three hurdles, I
think it is a little bit easier,
but again I can't really
think of a reason why
that we wouldn't look
at helping veterans.
I say that because not
just because I am a veteran
but at some point, those men and
women that may be in the units
that are [inaudible]
uniform, they wore a uniform
and they decided at some point
they were going to protect us
and I think for that
we still owe them.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
That is such a great point.
I just want to quickly
point out that
if you are running a vet court
or you are running a housing
unit, it's really important
that you track data-- that you
justify why this programming is
so important.
We all know anecdotally
that these programs work
and they are effective in that
we are reducing [inaudible],
but if you are listening out
there and you are in charge
of your dataset, make
sure you are tracking this
and reporting it back
and letting us know
how effective these are
so we can keep building it.
>> Unidentified Speaker: Let me
ask you as a general population,
how well do veterans do if,
let's say this program
didn't exist,
nobody was instituting
it, and you start veteran
with a minor infraction
in general population,
what happens to them?
>> Unidentified Speaker:
From what I have read
and from what I have discussed
with folks and interviewed,
again in general
population, they don't do well
because there is no
support system there.
They don't want to fight
without the guys [inaudible]
because you want
to fight with them.
You need to have something
where you can depend on someone
where you can watch his six
and he can watch your six.
It doesn't happen in gen pop.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
And if they come
into general population and
don't receive any services,
they are going to leave
without any services
and without any direction
and they are probably going
to be back very, very shortly
or at least with a program
such as this you are at least
making them aware what services
are available, you
are making them aware
of what benefits they are
eligible for because a lot
of times you will find that
the veteran doesn't realize
that he is eligible for any.
Veterans, especially
if they have less
than an honorable discharge,
they think that there is
nothing available to them
when that is not true.
>> Unidentified Speaker: Let
us talk about the pitfalls
because there are some
jurisdictions probably,
after watching right now,
saying, oh, I would love
to do it, but this is
going to be a hurdle.
Talk to me about some of the
issues that sort of stood
in the way that you
quickly overcame
and how you overcame
those pitfalls?
>> Unidentified Speaker:
The biggest issue
for us was probably
classifications.
Getting classifications on board
because obviously
classifications is a real key
part of it because
they determine whether
or not the individual
has any gang history,
what his sophistication
is, and a lot of times
that is how an individual
is housed, and for a veteran
if he has got some
things in his background
that could exclude
him programming.
So, if you have classifications
on board,
they know that it is a veteran,
you could look at that veteran
on a case by case basis, why
did you have these gang ties,
can you put those gang ties off
to the side, are you willing
to participate in treatment.
And for us in California,
now they have what is
called milestones credits,
so whether you are in county
jail, whether you are in prison,
for your participation and
any treatment or any type
of programming that is
going to give you time off
of your sentence,
so that is another.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
Lets quickly get
some thoughts shared.
>> Unidentified Speaker: I was
just going to say just getting
by in from the staff there
unless you want to start
in the program depending on
the number of veterans you have
in your organization to
get some form of push back.
That pushback can be in the form
of some veterans
actually thought
about establishing
a housing unit
that would somehow
diminish their service.
Once you do buy in and
do training with them,
they quickly realize that
there are some benefits
in there of having a program.
>> Judge Jackson: I think the
staff issue is the main thing,
training the staff, making
sure they understand it,
and also convincing
people outside community
and inside the jail facility
that these veterans are
not getting a break.
They are being put
together because, one,
there is less problem, less
time they are going to be spent
in confinement and reduced
privileges and you are going
to have necessary fewer guards
involved in guarding these vets.
So, there is an advantage that
can be assessed that will be
of benefit to the veterans
and to the jail facility.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
I think for anybody
who reads this publication,
a lot of those answers will
be found here, what you have
to overcome, what you have to
think about when you want to set
up a specialized housing,
call it whatever you want,
for what do you have
to really consider,
and if you have objections,
how do you overcome those
objections, and realistically,
most of the objections
can be overcame
with just speaking
rationally and dealing
with any problems,
if they come up.
>> Unidentified Speaker: Okay.
>> Unidentified Speaker: Great.
>> Unidentified Speaker:
I kind of want to talk
about the publication as well.
We want to encourage books
that read this publication.
There are four examples of
positive things happening
in jurisdictions
across the county.
These are ideas for
you to consider.
We structured this publication
around design, development,
implement, and sustain.
There are examples from
each of these books along
with King County,
Seattle, Washington,
and the HUMV Program
of Middlesex County.
Each of these folks, I
know would, if you reached
out to them, they would gladly
talk to you about, you know,
the successes, the
challenges, the lessons learned,
but a lot of that
stuff is in here.
Contact me at gcrawford@bop.gov
and we can have a conversation.
Any of these folks here will
gladly give you their time.
Thank you for joining us today.
>> Karen Lloyd: Thank you, John.
It has been my pleasure.
Anybody have any questions
before we say good afternoon
to you.
Any questions at all.
No questions?
Did a great job of
explaining to you all?
Thank you very much
for being here.
Thank you, guys for
being here as well.
[ Applause ]